is there a difference in how you feel
when you are making decisions by
yourself or where
your family involved and now that you
are part of the gates family has that
changed how you think about what you do
well I think it's sort of a complicated
question growing up my family was really
not very philanthropic my father was
very cautious his father growing up
during the Depression and it was only
this this corporation foundation they
gave really small scholarships and we
still do it as my one connection with my
cousins but after moving to Seattle and
also at that time my parents created a
foundation and they gave each of us a
certain amount each year to give away in
our communities that made me start
really thinking about what I was going
to do and then with the gates family
even though my giving is separate and so
is my husbands and our finances are
separate so mines kind of mild by
comparison or modest by comparison to
other members of the family I think you
know we talked about it a lot and talked
about you know what you're giving to
what you're assessing and tau and then
the foundation the Gates Foundation
started in our basement and Bill and
Melinda suddenly decided that they look
that they really wanted to give but they
were both working full-time at Microsoft
and so bills dad whose first wife had
passed away and then we were together he
offered to help and so one day we look
downstairs and the largest foundation of
the world was in our basement and there
were three people working for it what's
that anyway now there are a thousand
people working for it and they've built
two huge buildings in Seattle and it's a
major major concern